so in this video we're going to talk
about protein there is so many
confusions about protein and also should
I have this amount or that amount or
should I be a vegetarian so I'm going to
clear up some common misconceptions
about protein one of the principal
principles behind any diet is to you
want to trigger fat burning right you
want to lose weight ah if we look at the
viewpoint of what hormones trigger fat
burning and what foods trigger those
hormones protein comes up very at the
top of the list so protein does trigger
the fat burning hormones okay
but you have to understand what is
approaching because in nature very few
things come in pure proteins they're
always a combination of proteins
carbohydrates and fats and if you're
basing your diet on a calorie counting
model which by the way is incorrect
you're going to be looking more at the
fat calories and avoiding those since
they have the most calories you're not
going to be looking at the protein part
of this okay so that's a misconception
and your entire diet is going to be
wrong or if you're looking at maybe the
Atkins diet and you're only focused on
protein and realize there's six other
types of foods that trigger fat burning
process but they're focused just on the
protein then you're going to ignore some
of the other pieces the possible puzzle
especially as it relates to the liver
function because the more the liver is
damaged the more the liver is
dysfunctional the older you get the less
the liver can function the less protein
you can digest so if you start
increasing too much protein it's going
to throw off something else and also if
the liver is not good you're not going
to be able to have the thyroid work as a
thyroid works through the liver as well
so anyway let's just talk about protein
and some of the misconceptions let's you
know you have people that say well I'm
eating protein I'm eating nuts okay well
let's take a look nuts
only have 15% protein that's not a lot
so you're not going to be triggering a
lot of fat burning with nuts and
it has 13% carbohydrates so that's
fairly low and those carbohydrates
aren't necessarily high sugar
carbohydrates they don't turn into sugar
very fast unless you have maybe cashews
but for the most part they don't turn in
the sugar very fat fast but they are
they are high in fat but now when we're
looking at the triggering the fat
burning process fat is neutral so in
other words we don't necessarily have to
worry about fats if you want to burn fat
through the hormone system but we do
have to worry about fats in relationship
to what it does to the liver so too much
fat can irritate and clog up the liver
and that's why a lot of times we need
nuts high in fat it irritates the gall
bladder so the way we counter that is we
we increase the greens the vegetables to
keep the liver healthy so as long as
you're having enough greens in the diet
about 6 or 7 cups a day you can pretty
much get away with fat and that includes
even bacon and things like that so
that's how we counter it but if you are
only eating fat and protein that can
aggravate the liver so what we want to
do is we want to keep the carbs
relatively on the low side but I'm not
talking about all carbs I'm talking
about the ones that turn into sugar fast
so even though vegetables are almost all
carbohydrate they're they're very high
in fiber and they're very low in sugar
and they don't turn on the fat they're
in soluble fiber so they don't really
turn into sugar on the other hand grains
are very high in carbs but they're
different than vegetable because they're
deterred in the sugar very very fast
okay so we want to we want a food that
has a bit higher amounts of protein a
bit low carb or carbs that don't break
it down in the sugar very easily and we
really don't care about the fats because
we're going to keep our vegetable
content very high to flush things out of
the liver all right so this whole
conception of high calorie high fat
turning the fat just take that and just
put it over here because that really
doesn't
affect insulin which is the thing that
really makes you get fat so and I know
people are in grits in their mind and
like oh my gosh I have to vote all fat
well how does that work in the for you
does it work I mean try it
you cut your fats out it never really
turns into weight loss it's the carbs
okay so we also have another factor here
called nutrients because what we want to
do is you want something high in
nutrients so let's just take out meal
for example oatmeal for breakfast is
like eating cardboard it's very low in
nutrients yes it has some factors that
help lower cholesterol a little bit but
as far as nutrients it's low all right
same thing with hummus hummus is a great
food but it's very low in nutrients okay
so if you're trying to eat foods that
increase the health if you have oatmeal
or hummus don't be surprised if they I
mean they're like a neutral food they
might not hurt you but they might not
help you again like eating cardboard
it's not going to kill you but it's not
going to help you so nuts
okay so nuts do have some good amount of
nutrients okay so we have that now beans
have 23 percent protein a bit more than
nuts but look at the carb 72% vs. 13% so
this is going to get you right here
those carbs now I'm not against beans
and look at how low they are in fat but
they do have a bit a bit too many carbs
too if you're trying to lose weight now
there's layers to this problem so it's
not just as simple as calories in equals
calories out or high protein or low fat
you have there's different layers of
complexities and I'm trying to make it
simple but one layer is this beans are
cooked so you actually destroy enzymes
and then you destroy nutrition so you're
eating kind of a dead product and also
even though they have higher
our protein the nuts they're very very
low in fat and also most vegetarian
programs say or low low fat diets say oh
yeah beans are great because there's
such low in fat and low in calorie and
they're going to you're just going to
burn off these calories but a lot of
these carbohydrates especially refined
beans will those that'll turn into sugar
pretty fast and black beans it's it's
not going to help your weight loss so we
have this food and then we have your
body interaction with it hormonal e if
your metabolism is low and that's
another variable if you consume some of
these foods too high in carb it's going
to create an effect on your metabolism
in fact it's going to slow you way down
if your metabolism is high you can get
away with all these carbs but and most
people especially if they reach the age
of 40 or 50 you're not going to be able
to get away with these higher
carbohydrate foods so even though you
might walk it off in a mile the insulin
response the sugar response could last
far more than that mile it could last
two three four days okay
so what you have to know is just a
little bit of the wrong thing can
nullify a lot of good things
alright so hope I'm not confusing you
too much here I probably am but let's
just kind of go through this so nuts
high in fat but that's okay if we keep
our vegetables high because it's higher
nutrients beans most of them are ugly
cooked you're not gonna eat raw beans
and so the nutrition is not as high with
beans but it's kind of a neutral food if
your metabolism is good if you trying to
lose weight you're going to find beans
might not help you lose weight and then
we have hummus again look at eleven
percent protein 45 percent carbs forty
four percent fat okay alright not too
bad it's not going to turn into sugar
that bad because there's a certain
amount of fiber but it's like a neutral
food because the nutrition is not very
high so it would be something to snack
on something to keep you going
but it's not necessarily going to help
you burn fat but it's not necessarily
going to cause you to gain weight either
so this is a neutral food now let's talk
about yogurt and cheese
now yogurt has 36% protein that's that's
not bad that's a good amount of protein
and then also cheese has a little higher
protein but it also depending on what
type of cheese that you consume because
the the more aged it is the higher
protein content in the less carbohydrate
because those enzymes or those bacteria
in the cheese that make these fermented
products like yogurt kefir and cheese
especially tend to eat up some of the
lactose the milk sugar in there reducing
the sugar so now we have all these
beneficial bacteria
we got great protein and we have some
fat as well especially if if the low-fat
cheese but we're not concerned about the
fat because we're adding our vegetables
very very hot so yogurt might help us
but look at it does have 29% sugar
I'm sorry carbohydrate so that is a bit
high so if you're trying to lose weight
you may find that yogurt might slow you
down a little bit but you depends on
your metabolism okay if your metabolism
is slow you might have to eliminate all
these high carb things definitely beans
definitely hummus and definitely yogurt
you could probably get by with cheese
though because cheese is not very high
in car but yogurt and kefir is but nuts
would be okay because look at how low
that would be 13% now let's get into the
grains grains have 15% protein that is
like very very low and look at how much
carb it's 75 percent carb but the
catch-22 with this carb it's this is not
like vegetable this is like turning in
the sugar very very fast so grains are
very very bad for weight loss yet
they're look at how low the aren't fats
so all these low fat diet so-called
gurus will say it's okay to consume
grains because it's such a low in fat
and
have complex carbohydrates and have
whole-grain not refined grain or white
bread well it doesn't matter whole grain
still turns in the sugar faster than
sugar some of these sugars turn affect
your blood sugars and there's a great
book that you can weep belly that talks
about how whole-grain is very very bad
advice so when you're consuming a diet a
balanced diet the food pyramid diet and
you have a fat situation stubborn belly
fat or whatever you you can't do a
balanced diet you can't do those little
protein bars that have you know balanced
proteins carbohydrates and fats why
because your body's out of balance so
you really have to force your body to
burn fat by reducing these carbs is far
down to zero as possible okay especially
the ones that turn the sugar so grains
will just block any chance of losing
weight and that also includes some fruit
as well so we're going to keep fruit
down as well so we have grains we have
low fat but it's so funny how people say
well you can eat you can have all these
great foods but just add grains well
that's enough to block any chance of
losing weight in plus there's very low
amounts of nutrition in grains now
yogurt there there's some great calcium
so that's a little bit higher okay but
grains are low grains are out okay fish
look at this ninety-three percent
protein oh my goodness that is a very
good fat burner and look at how many
carbohydrates 0 huge ability to burn fat
but again the principles there's layers
of complexity you have also too much
protein so you wouldn't want necessarily
live on protein or have like 12 ounces
per meal because that can also bog down
the liver all the fat burning hormones
that come through the body go through
the liver so we need that keep that
liver opened up and healthy and then if
we're burning fat
we better consume a lot of vegetables
because if you don't all the fat that
you are burning ends up in the liver and
stuck in the liver and you end up with a
fatty liver that's why a lot of the
Atkins diet people or the high protein
diet people end up with the fatty liver
and that's why their breath is kind of
toxic and so we want to understand the
whole picture so fish look at this
7% fat I mean that's a low stress on
your liver and people I say what's the
best proteins for for the body well we
what will be the best protein to lessen
the stress on your liver fish would be
great seafood would be even better so
those are very low liver stress proteins
now animal protein 59% protein that's
pretty high but look at 0% carb so
animal protein will also help you burn
fat but look it out much higher it is in
fat so again if you're going to do
animal protein you better enhance the
vegetables to clean out that fat but you
know what you could probably get away
with if you were to consume just fish
because this is low in protein I'm sorry
fat you pretty much can get away with
eating mostly fish if there's small
amounts of fish through the day because
it's not going to be stress on your
liver or your pancreas it'll put you in
some hardcore fat burning and then
there's different types of fish too like
halibut is higher in fat this is cod cod
is low in fat but of course it's you
have to make it taste good
alright so now we have kale 16% protein
Wow that's actually more than nuts it's
more than hummus and it's more than
grains wow there's protein and count
what do you know but look at how high it
is in carbohydrate 72% but none of this
just turns into sugar very fast so it's
low glycemic it's high in fiber and it's
in soluble fiber so your digestion is
going to not break that down into direct
sugar so it takes a lot of energy to
break that down so you're going to hate
you it's kind of like you're going to
burn more fat just breaking the stuff
down and then of course 15%
but these are healthy fats these are
omega-3 fats omega-6 fats so it's pretty
low in fat and so it is you can see it's
screaming high with nutrients so we have
the perfect food right here kale all
right now look at eggs 29% protein you
would think that would be higher in
protein but it's not very high in
protein but it's not very low in protein
very low in carbs oh so eggs also are
going to help you lose weight because
look at that carb is only 2% and we have
a lot of nutrition as well but it's very
high in fat so eggs are fine but they
could stress a liver a little bit if
you're not having enough vegetable all
right so I hope I clarified some of the
confusions about protein you might want
to watch this several times take some
notes so apply the information and we
will see you in the next video